hey everybody what's going on welcome to
the live Q&A for Conan without borders
yes for the next for the next 30 minutes
we'll be taking your questions right
here on YouTube also around histogram my
Instagram
how's it going over there with me today
is pose Danny
Jesse Gaskell Mike Sweeney of course
Conan O'Brien thanks guys I feel like
he's famous enough where it's a little
bit different we're backstage here at
the show and we have all these amazing
props behind us guys let's just art how
did this originally come about how do
why did we go to Ghana can I just point
out up top usually I'm crippled leg for
speaking too loudly
that's this time I actually think it may
be justified yes because none of us are
wearing microphones yeah that's right
and we were in a big empty space so for
the first time bleh has found a room
that fits the volume of his voice your
outdoor voice I pulled a lot of strings
so that I could finally not get yelled
at one time writing a live Q&A well then
a lot of favors for that so
I think everybody always asked where are
we going next so how do we choose god
well as will pass the ball to Mike
Sweeney Mike Sweeney was the one who I
think you were the one that notified me
that we had an official invitation is
that ladder
Jason Shalini are three others are got
an invitation from the country of Ghana
from the government to help commemorate
year of return which is milestone so and
then we just you know
so many who's 56 countries America and
it was daunting to decide where to go
this helped helped give us some
direction and the more we yeah read
about Ghana it seemed like such a great
place to yes it was a reason to go you
know we really wanted to go to Africa
but we didn't want to do the oh look
we're on a safari and I'm wearing a pith
helmet and there's a lion we actually
wanted to go in some way that was
meaningful and organic to what's
happening right now and so when we
started reading about Ghana and year of
return and the fact that so many people
were going back to Ghana to or going to
Ghana for the first time to explore
their roots and come to grips with this
and then we try dream on going on and
finding out what an amazing amazing
country it is and just what a success
story Ghana has been and culturally
economically they have done such an
incredible job we thought this is a
great story let's go and a maybe try and
put whatever small spotlight we have on
this but also let's find out what it's
what's going on and and from the minute
we landed the people were very funny
they have a terrific sense of humor and
just natural improvisers they were all
very funny and willing to play along and
and also just the the comedy of most of
them thinking that I was a sickly white
woman just naturally it was really funny
right off the bat we actually have some
questions from folks at in Ghana this
one comes from a mayor Deborah and she
has what was the one biggest culture
shock you experienced during your visit
to Ghana okay because the biggest
culture shock was just discovering that
well there was no single biggest culture
shock
I I really actually I'm having trouble
answering the question to get the word
out Jose was two words together there
was not as big a culture shock because
the language is English everybody
encountered spoke English and of course
you know Thuy another other language God
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
was able to you know myself very well
there yes better there than here I found
it really gave me pause what I've been
thinking about it a lot since was the
number of times that I would go out at
night and look around and realize that
maybe I'm the only white person here or
we're the only white people here and it
was this role reversal that that did
sort of I don't know awaken my sense of
like how how strange that must be to be
the only person color this situation
yeah yeah then we went to we went to a
club one night and I walked in first and
I just I was just really I thought oh
I'm understanding I mean not that I've
tried to understand there's only so much
you can understand and then you get into
a situation where oh my god this is what
a lot of people everyday yeah so that
was sort of profound realization for me
and there was but I was I have to say I
do agree with with Jose in that answers
don't have to make sense
I agree with Jose that you one of the
things that it's sort of it wasn't
shocking but it was amazing how everyone
speaks English and and I think we
appreciated right away there's this
disparity you can be a marketplace that
really feels like it's 800 years old and
it's in this open marketplace and it
very much feels like you've gone to a
different world
and then we would get back in their van
and drive two minutes and there was a
Porsche dealership and and you know
people you know and you realise that
this is a country that's gone through an
incredible transition and and there is
so much about it that there was the
unfamiliar and then I think what was
sometimes shocking was just how much of
the familiar there was someone actually
shouted out to us at one point hey make
sure you make point we all don't you
know live you know
his law firm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
well I want to be my body you look
stubbly in the music video you did
something with Towanda Eugenie and what
were your feelings and it's a joke I'm
in this music video with these real
dancers professional dancer professional
musicians so I got to be kind of funny
you know just show up and instantly the
choreographer was no no wait a minute
we're going to get this right yeah yes
yes and he it was hot we were out on the
street broke away you know have you
dance and the choreographer just going
through
[Music]
you were exhausted I was really tired
and the guy was like again again do you
have it
left foot and if I made the slightest
mistake look at me like come on man full
disclosure was they'd slotted it to our
two days earlier we need to know so I
had you very quickly and next time I
think we should get better recording
devices so if there was a crane and
there's a lot at the attachment and
immediately felt like you might have
benefit you know here I was scared
I will say that I was scared because I'm
there and I'm in this on a real there
they were very professional they were
all very good I kept apologizing to
beautiful women like I'm sorry I know
you're all really good dancers you know
come on that's one right foot right foot
left foot then they ended around
but I think we should go back to the
main question started with more of a
comment which is that I looked very
snugly to everything everybody drifts
away from I look suddenly that was
because of what you that's what you
should be wearing
yeah also what are my favorite parts of
the trip bladder but one of my favorite
part oh my god you actually tell me you
louder yeah we have not a teep right
if you're a person trip actually was we
went straight in the Kwame Eugene video
to us we want to Sam Richardson and he
is family invited us to their house and
you actually kept when we went to eat a
meal at his house yeah so I was dressed
like this rap star this is gonna hand
rap star when I showed up with
sandwiches family I have to say I have
to give major props to plum Eugene and
everybody man they're they're fantastic
and they went their way to make me look
good and if they can make me look good
they should all get a Nobel Prize
[Laughter]
wearing the nicest dress then notices
you know your little sides a little
dagger II was sort of a dark shirt a
gray sweater we all look like we're
depressed yeah we all look like we're
going through a depression and then you
go to these other countries is gonna
smite the best examples so far yeah
where they say hey we're here for a
brief time on this planet there's great
colors and dyes let's use them and
celebrate life yeah actually pod Joe is
watching on Instagram he says great to
see you entering into the coffin I made
for you yes thank you Paco for making my
vessel that will take me to what I saw
Conan Agassi I chose a coffin of himself
to be buried in what would you guys you
heard it
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
Steve Harvey's let's talk remote about
Sam Richards me we brought Sam
Richardson who brought secretin with us
what does bringing someone like Sam add
to the trip both on camera and off Sam
has Bruce and so it was perfect
I mean he's this incredibly talented
funny nice person and the minute you
know I had interviewed him on the show
but I didn't know him well and I knew
him from Detroiters and from vite but I
didn't really know him as a person and
then we met him at the airport on our
way at Ghana and within seconds he's the
funniest guy in the room he was cracking
this up Athena
yeah and he's so relaxed and he it was
just very nice to when someone like me
goes to a country like Ghana is
important you know I think to have an
emissary someone who can who can tell me
how they're feeling about the trip you
know what are they experiencing what
does this mean for them yeah so it's not
just me whether any and I can I like
Stephen young when we went to the DMZ
exactly are we stopped shooting
what camera happened to be on you guys
but the sound guy was there and you guys
improvised in real time
with milk chocolate and it was in real
time and it was this perfect thing yet
we were so nervous when we came back
because we discovered we weren't
recording to sound so there's all this
market sound and that was the one and
you can see that he's just such a good
he's such a good yes and ER as they say
an improv and has such really funny
instincts and was just you know just a
lovely guy to spend time with yeah and
one of the you know yeah and like you
mentioned he's kind of descended from
royalty and so Jordan on YouTube asked
how is the experience of being in front
of royalty we met wooden wheel that was
in Kumasi we traveled to the cultural
and the center of the a we flew and that
was that was a surreal moment and again
I believe there was a lot of cook with
doctor in that case there was
[Music]
then we went in with royal family that
was I've never experienced anything like
that before we're all nervous we want to
be good ambassadors from the United
States yeah as we're learning right now
in the news they don't do anything
anyway but anyway we we wanted to be
good ambassadors good citizens we wanted
to be respectful and so we're actually I
was nervous and I think Sam was nervous
too yeah and we're in this room with
tribal chiefs and her court and he's
doing a ceremony ceremony oh and there
was a lot of week we were told what
gifts to bring and so we brought these
gifts and it was all you know us trying
to be on our best behavior
and then the one thing that was really
crazy is in the corner of the room you
can't see it on TV okay there is a
television a flat-screen television so
it's this very formal ceremonial
environment in the corner there's a
flat-screen television on and it's
showing sucker
I think either soccer or rugby Sunday
Windows and and sometimes the local news
but it's just something that we'd be on
in a sports ball and so I could notice
every now and then that the Chiefs would
be listening to us in their eyes you
tripped over belay no good we scored a
point
[Laughter]
that'll be me on then I'll be me on the
late night show in five years you know
our next guest is Matt Damon and Andy
will pick up that go like that and then
you'll move my mouth I love you can't
speak directly I believe that's the
first time in any of our travel shows
that we've encountered royalty that's
amazing
also I wanna give a shout out to cool
peeps calm move our that's a ghana blog
and they're watching that they say they
love i don't know cool peach is that
song blowing up tell us I know that's
all all respect goes to Quan - Eugene he
if anything I got in the way but but I
want to thank I want to thank that
people have gone in climbing trips and
Rex for being so patient with me thank
you
and one thing I thought that was
fantastic on the show is you and Sam
went to not on the ground he has a very
famous showing Donna called Mike Brown's
kitchen how did we find
we just researched local shows there
yeah we always do
that that show came up with some popular
cooking show we've never done so it
seemed like a good yeah and it was she
is in force of nature and I've worked
with immune I've worked with Martha
Stewart I've worked with I've worked
with many people that are powerful
personalities and cyclones and energy
and commanding and I don't know anybody
who can handle she was fantastic and
she's very very charismatic and and it
was actually that segment who was
actually kind of easy because there was
no thinking involved she told me to do
that by the way these schools / yes she
oh oh yeah that's way down on her list
of languages she's coming she's like
everywhere else we drove in a crowd
everywhere there's giant billboards of
her her face was everywhere like I'd go
to bed at night in a poster look economy
falls in history Manassas what was your
favorite local dish you made a jollof
with that is one of her favorite
restaurants now in people you know
people say like oh but you you've you
know you've you've been to Italy and
you've been to you know you get a sushi
in Japan and
yeah yeah minute we must our minds for
that chicken and we became addicts for
it and we would formally would find out
that oh they just got some more and it's
on the bus we would start rocking Jesse
got a little obsessed with something
[Music]
which I showed up to lady Mae yeah lady
Mae did such a lovely job of helping put
all this together and then she came to
Los Angeles for the screening and she
was there for the screening and I think
she had a I mean she was there for the
when we take the show with an audience
and showed it to an audience then when
it air I think she got a watching part
she did yeah two people parents went to
another screaming she's when we say
fixer she's like our local produced yes
and every country would go to Jason
schlemm he looks up but like I'll talk
to two or three people and he always
just on the phone zero so not one person
yeah and yeah in quato on YouTube who is
in Ghana says they really happy that you
liked it and thank you for really to the
people Ghana for being so gracious to us
allowing us to come and being just a
real honor for us yeah and we're almost
out of time but a red clay on Instagram
asked the question that everyone always
asks where next where we're going pretty
much Florida anywhere in the Panhandle
right would you want to go cold do you
want to go hot do you want to go
whatever weird any any you know they're
not these things were a little bit
subject there's a lot of it can happen
in one of two ways sometimes we have a
obviously we have a bunch of places that
we have in mind we can't disclose those
yet but then sometimes something will
come up the Greenland show right happen
again the Franklin the president
announced he might want to buy Greenland
and we were there I think three days
later kicking the tires on the deal so
you never know you never know where we
will go next yeah
we are the Bering Strait were you guys
meet venture I mean what episode of
Colonel Edwards is this is this 14 13 13
so we we have got a lot of stamps on the
passport were were you guys well travel
before starting from the borders how is
like this yeah I thought it was pretty
well-traveled but this has really upped
my game and with any luck not would we
get to keep going you know I mean we
just meaning I hope that we get to do
this for quite a while because it just
it really is a labor of love it's one of
the most exciting in a long career of
things that I've been excited about it's
hard to match any of these other
countries and trying to do
improvisational comedy with people that
often don't speak the language or where
where I'm always the odd man out
is really fun it's really great yeah is
there any any country you would go back
to I go back to Armenia
I really had a good time in Armenian on
my music so I went back to the house
there where she was born
so yes also actually on YouTube since I
said I wasn't born there people on
YouTube want to say it we're almost done
anyway thank you guys for joining us
for the live Q&A code upwards got very
much audio and joses thing but by
watching the show you watch behind the
scenes and everything we did a team coca
/ Ghana see you guys
[Music]